Speaker 1: Hey, I'm going to show you some amazing
stuff. Fox News had to spend the day yesterday
covering this historic record breaking heat wave
in the United States. In Europe, they had to do
it. They had to cover this story because it was
such a major story without talking about climate
change and the fact that for decades now we are
seeing more and more higher high temperatures,
record high temperatures, extreme heat and extreme
cold and extreme weather events, all of which a
comprehensive climate change model would predict
and expect. This is just wild, wild stuff. So
let's start with some of the images that appeared
on Fox News. And they don't mention climate
change. They talk about it's hot, but they don't
talk about the relationship to climate change.
Excess heat. Parts of the U.S. face warnings
and advisories. Major story on Fox News.
No mention of climate change. Drought monitor
exceptional drought arid conditions carry
tinderbox effect. Of course, a very high fire
risk. Another aspect of climate change and how
climate change can influence it can influence the
amount of land you have that is potentially useful
for growing food when these fires run through.
Okay. We've talked about it before. Drought
monitor, Dallas, triple digit temperatures,
weather conditions forecast to continue.
Insane temperatures in Dallas. Dallas, including
highs of 109 and 108 this week. All of these
stories didn't mention climate change once.
Now, I know it's Fox News. I know it's Fox News.
But still, it is notable that they go out of their
way not to talk about climate change. Let's look
at a segment. This is Brett Beyer from FOX News.
Speaker 2: Breaking tonight, much of Europe is
experiencing record temperatures as a brutal
heat wave rolls through the continent.
Britain shattered its all time record with a
reading of 104.4 degrees Fahrenheit, of course,
at Heathrow Airport. London's mayor says the
temperatures are causing a huge surge in the
number of fires in the city. One grassfire in
Wellington required more than 100 firefighters to
come to that scene. Ferocious wildfires continue
in south southwestern France. More than 2000
firefighters have been deployed there. Tens
of thousands of people have been evacuated.
Nearly 750 health related deaths have already
been reported in Spain and neighboring Portugal.
More than 30 forest fires around Spain have
forced thousands of evacuations. Many parts
of this country are also dealing with record
heat. Robert Ray of Fox Weather has specifics
from Round Rock, Texas, which can't be cool.
Speaker 1: By the way. Remember, Fox Weather is
the new Fox News Weather Channel. That's that's
a whole other thing where it's the it's the
version. I mean, listen, it's they do
some weather, but it's the way to now
make weather political. And we've talked about
that before as well. Let's continue.
Speaker 2: Today. Good evening, Robert.
Good evening, Bret. I found a little shade
here in the Lone Star State and I will say
over 100 million people across the U.S. are
experiencing excessive heat warnings and not a
good situation. 60 million of those people are in
the lower Mississippi Valley, the southern plains.
And here in Texas, Dallas, the big D expected
to be about 110 soon. Oklahoma City actually
did hit 110 degrees. That's the first time since
August of 2011. And the state capital of Austin,
about 110, San Antonio, El Paso, even over
to Shreveport, Louisiana now. And you see
that big orange ball. That is the sun.
Speaker 1: That is the sun. Folks do not
be confused. That orange ball is indeed the
sun. Now, a re a reasonable question would be,
is there anything systemic going on that might
be leading to us doing this every summer, every
summer, saying record high, record high, never
seen before. Now you might come back and say,
but David, I thought weather wasn't climate and
you were correct and. Individual weather event
is not the same thing as climate. A single,
stronger than usual unseasonably late hurricane
doesn't really tell us anything about
what's happening with the climate.
But multiple decades of higher high temperatures,
lower low temperatures, unseasonably warm,
unseasonably cold, stronger and more and stronger
hurricanes. During hurricane season, all of those
things, not just one day start to tell us about
the climate of a place and whether the climate
is changing. So a weather event would be, oh,
a crazy heat wave in New York City one time.
The change of climate would be every summer. The
average temperature in New York City, as well as
the number of days that reach triple digits,
goes up. And you observed that over multiple
decades. Now we're talking about a change to the
climate of a place that goes beyond an individual.
It's sort of like the same thing I talked about.
It was either last week or the week before.
Why is it that anecdotal evidence is bad? Well,
it's it's not so much that anecdotal evidence
is bad when it's comprehensively
collected, systematized and used to
ascertain patterns. But then it's no longer
anecdotal. Then it's how we gather data,
individual anecdotes, insufficient anecdotes out
of context. Anecdotes are what aren't useful. So
that's what's going on. This is the exact
pattern that is predicted by climatologists
erratic weather, unseasonable weather, records of
different kinds, stronger storms, drought, etc.,
etc.. That's exactly what's happening in Fox News
because it's Fox News doing everything they can
not to talk about climate until nighttime and I
won't even get into this. But then at night they
started ridiculing the climate change believers.
The people that accept science with stuff like
liberals shocked that it's hot in the summer.
Which of course, kind of misses the point.
We'll keep talking about it. The heat wave
will continue and we'll have we'll actually
have more about this on the bonus show.